following the debacle over dominic raab
being off last week i can tell you that
the minister responsible for afghanistan
in the foreign office which is lord
ahmed of wimbledon was also on leave
last week as kabul fell to the taliban
you can see him here he's been in his
post for four years he's a minister of
state for south asia and has been
following developments in afghanistan
including the peace talks for the past
year or more he was away on a staycation
last week
and
bringing more questions about the
foreign office's readiness for that
lightning taliban advance on kabul but
it also raises an important question
about why when dominic robb did not make
the call to the afghan foreign minister
on friday afternoon and it was instead
delegated we here to zach goldsmith who
is the minister for the pacific and also
splits his time with the environment
department and in fact of course that
call was never made
why
lord ahmed was not asked to make that
call as uh hanif atma the afghan foreign
minister is someone who he has dealt
with a lot over the last couple of years
so more questions about the foreign
office's readiness and response to
the taliban advance in afghanistan
raised by the fact that lord ahmed was
also absent
now i've had a statement from the
foreign office which i can give you on
this a spokesperson said lord ahmed has
been working closely with the foreign
secretary and the fcdo team throughout
the response to events in afghanistan
including engaging with international
partners and i understand that although
he since he was in the uk last week he
was following this closely and was also
working on cases raised by mps of people
brits and afghans who were stuck in
afghanistan and needed to get out
so if he was working on that last week
questions raised about why he was not
asked to make that call
which critics say could have got the
ball rolling on some of the evacuations
that we've seen happen so chaotically
over the last few days or so